so peter strzok okay james comey
james comey parties with hillary clinton
and bill clinton his wife they've
supported their campaign okay
peter strzok hey texts come out this is
what we're willing to do x y z
you know there's no way we're gonna let
him win you know in the texts we can see
the text right okay
you seem like a reasonable guy you seem
like a nice guy
you seem like a uh guy
that you're like a trifecta
uh i would have a blast having party
with you go and partying with you and we
were 20s we'd have a blast together if
we added it maybe we'd go to jail but we
still have a blast together
number two you're the kind of guy that i
you know enjoy watching a game with and
we're sitting there talking and you know
and then three i feel comfortable for my
family and my kids to meet you and we
you know you go to the house bring you
to my place you give that vibe okay
you're a man's man you give very peace
comfort all that stuff
i can't say that about everybody and we
can't say that the ci is a hundred
percent bulletproof hiring process
because you can't read in the minds of
everyone and i understand how some
people that are fully non-emotional that
can be also psychological where a person
can be
extremely narcissistic or whatever they
can manipulate that's probably not a
person they want to hire as well
but how do people like peter struck how
do people like that get in
where they represent an institution that
we have to trust an agency that's
essentially working to protect me
how do
they
prevent from their emotions
and their friendships and the parties
they get invited to and the communities
they live in
how do they say listen we may be best
friends i may support you but you're
going to jail okay that's a very hard
thing for a person to do once you're
fully vested with someone right there's
a reason how they say in hollywood a lot
of big celebrities they don't go on
social media
if you notice the big names they are not
on twitter
you can't find a daniel day-lewis on
twitter you can't find any of these big
actors on twitter because for them is
the moment we open our mouth and give
you our opinions it's very hard for us
to act because now you see us in a
certain way right okay
that's very deep to me very like this
guy that played the elvis presley i
don't know what the guy's name is
incredible job i was watching all his
interviews i was so flabbergasted by the
guy i was really blown but there's
nothing on the guy right how what kind
of an artist he is
but for this side
i have a hard time believing that even
these agents on the inside can let their
emotions get in a way where they help
one side of the political party over the
other side no it is again let's if we
skip the
idolized phase and we skip the demonized
phase we go straight to humanize phase
that's you're you're explaining exactly
why that happens
of course they're swayed by their
emotions we're all swayed by our
emotions we go through specific training
to to
de-uh de-incentivize our emotional
decision making and increase our
dependence on rational decision making
but it's still a process it has to be
trained it has to be practiced
it has to be
exercised
oftentimes when you're making emotional
decisions you're not giving yourself
space or time to train or exercise
you're just in a moment making an
emotional decision that's a very human
thing to do
we all do it i don't know uh peter peter
strzok so i don't know him personally i
can't speak to his specific credentials
whether he was blue badge cia green
badge cia related to c i have no idea
what his role was there but what i do
know is the men and women inside cia
when i was fbi but peter struck as fbi
thank you very much so when i was inside
federal government
inside specifically inside cia
we're we are always taught to expect and
predict that we will think and act
emotionally and then try and take steps
to limit that so that we can give
ourselves the space to let our rational
brain keep up if you're interested in
the cognitive cycle i can give it about
two minutes go forward so every human
brain we call it we call it pink matter
it's like a computer in your head
you have two sides the left side and the
right side we all know that what we
don't know is that one side works faster
than the other side right your your left
brain is your logical brain your right
brain is your creative or emotional
brain your right brain works faster than
your left brain it's because your right
brain depends on these things called
cognitive biases or cognitive
connections
these inferences that it builds over
time so that it can jump from conclusion
to conclusion skipping logic that's why
if you're a if you're a butt guy
right you don't even you just you are
attracted or not attracted in an instant
based off of the thing that you're
interested in right if you're a girl
that likes a certain kind of shoe or
certain kind of purse you're attracted
to it immediately your brain is skipping
the logical step if your right brain if
your left brain was in charge it would
say what is that is it real how much
does it cost can i get access to it
that's four steps compared to the one
step that says i like it i want it
sales people understand this
intrinsically even though they may not
be able to put words to it make it so
that it triggers a right brain reaction
and the sales process will move faster
if you're trying to sell through a left
brain process the sales cycle cycle's
going to move slower try to talk about
the features and benefits whatever else
so
they train us
to slow down our right brain and speed
up our left brain and there's exercises
and practices you can do that it's one
of the things that i teach my my
executives now and one of the things i
teach my sales teams now so that people
can
kind of reprogram the pink matter so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here